We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2.
David P..
Here is a voicemail about mail in voting.
A very important topic this election cycle.
Take a listen.
We need to push the mail in vote regardless
of what he says in numbers.
We need to push the mail vote.
Absolutely agree.
Listen, 20 20 could come down to mail in voting.
We just don't know what the state of the pandemic
is going to be in November.
If the numbers continue to decline between
now and then, we could have a safe ish situation
to go out and vote in person in November.
But there are still going to be people that
will be scared and rightfully so, because
we are not going to eradicate this in any
significant way, maybe ever.
I mean, it might become just a seasonal thing
where you have to manage it with a seasonal
corona virus vaccine.
We just don't know.
But it will still be here in some capacity
in November.
If we are in the middle of a second wave in
November, then waiting on setting up vote
by mail is going to be too late.
There will be states who won't be able to
do it.
It'll be a disaster.
So the caller could not be more right.
We need to be pushing for vote by mail now.
And fortunately, some states are doing it
now.
Even places like Texas, at least for now,
are allowing anybody who wants an absentee
ballot to get an absentee ballot.
And it's valid to say the reason I want one
is I'm afraid of getting corona virus that
is valid even in Texas right now.
But depending on the numbers, by November,
it may no longer apply to the November presidential
election.
Understand that Trump has no federal authority
to ban vote by mail.
Trump also has no federal authority to designate
churches, essential organizations or whatever
the case may be.
But that doesn't mean Trump isn't going to
run propaganda on this.
He's already been pushing vote by mail leads
to voter fraud.
It's not true.
The data don't suggest that.
Don't demonstrate it in any way whatsoever.
But we are starting to see local Republican
officials take a cue from Trump and start
to say it causes fraud.
It opens the door to fraud.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Let's not allow them to do that.
Let's lobby all of our states to say, at minimum,
it doesn't.
We're not saying right now.
Cancel in-person voting.
We're just we don't need to do that.
All we need is a rule that says if you want
to vote by mail, you can and you will not
have to justify it because you're out of state.
You will not.
You can just request an absentee ballot period.
Better is we will send everyone an application
for an absentee ballot, which they have to
return to get an absentee ballot.
Even better is we will send everyone an actual
absentee ballot.
Now, different states have different rules
about what's allowed in terms of automatically
sending people absentee ballots versus, well,
you can't do that.
You've got to send them an application.
Every state is different.
It's a patchwork of 50 different elections.
Let's go for the gold, which is send everybody
an absentee ballot and let them vote by mail.
If not, send everybody an absentee ballot
application.
If not, let everybody request an absentee
ballot for any reason, even if it doesn't
meet the previously established requirements
for why one would get an absentee ballot.
We can do this.
And one last thing on this.
I'm spending more time on this than I planned
to, but this is important.
It only really matters in a few states.
Right.
I mean, listen, California, whether they vote
by mail or not, Biden is going to win California.
Massachusetts.
Biden's going to win Massachusetts, Utah.
Trump's going to win Utah, I think.
Although I actually saw one poll which says
it's not as out of reach for Biden as you
might imagine.
But Trump's likely going to go to win Utah.
We need to focus our efforts in particular
states.
Republicans know this, right?
We're talking about Pennsylvania, Florida,
Ohio, Michigan, Wisconsin.
I'm not getting all of them.
That's where we need to focus our efforts.
We've got a fantastic bonus show for you today.
I will recap my appearance on the Joe Rogan
experience last week.
I have a new rabbit problem.
You are not going to believe what I have dealt
with over the last 48 hours.
Some of you will.
Some of you won't.
And also, we will talk about a rat problem.
Rats are finding less trash to eat because
a lot of commercial spaces that generate huge
amounts of trash are essentially closed, not
generating trash.
Rats are becoming cannibalistic because of
the trash shortage due to coronavirus.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Don't miss it.
Sign up at going to happen dot com and I will
see that.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.